right that boss oh it's a surprise for
them surprise person give it to me baby
where's your favorite place on earth
my husband's arms ah but it is lying on
his chest oh yeah I love it
hearing his heartbeat I know I'm so
corny but it's true night in or night
owl sweet for me I think probably night
in now with my baby son bear am I
missing so ask your breasts I see oh so
you know I'm drunk yes if your partner
gave you a free pass see would you use
on whoever she wants me to use on a song
at the moment
Oh anything by storms needs to be honest
oh yeah I came out not only if I got
excited with him but I gave him a shout
out it must be what was the last gift
you gave someone I just gave my sister
the gift back from this event breakfast
lunch or dinner
well I've merged them all into one thing
called Brynner who was my first kiss
grab almost 40 I don't remember how I
think it's a boy named Ranil in my high
school well maybe it was hard for ever
enough yeah yeah definitely run now so
it's your best dance move I know that I
think probably the most rebellious thing
that I've done is that tonight I am
drinking starting author what is your
guilty pleasure
Bui I don't think this is guilty but I
enjoy cooking shows Kapoor do you like
baked oh I love makeup yeah you know for
the Brits out there Americans learned
about all the different accents Rubik's
Cube a cup yes sir chief accountant
[Music]
who did or alive would you have a drink
with well I have to say Michael Jackson
I think it's the most obvious answer but
I mean you use the greatest form in the
world I just want to know how the hell
he had all the time to learn and do that
cuz I've only just started dancing
myself and it's so hard yeah and what do
we do
he just want it day yeah what's the most
rebellious thing you've ever done I
can't answer it I went out with a
criminal he was in prison
oh wait wow yeah my least favorite drink
would probably be Bovril if you have to
star in a reality TV show which would it
be probably good probably you know as
well unfortunately - show she lets dance
move get your if your partner gave you a
free pass to you you know there was a
lot of cute guys on stage tonight
whoever that fighter was great I do
Joshua rhyme guy don't be great oh my
favorite yeah I'm too drunk
awesome evil beer beer
nah man you do oh yeah
[Music]